[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or as we like to call its dear Charlie
and Jimmy and Hank
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the weekly podcast where I hang
green and usually John Green but this
week Charlie McDonnell and Jimmy Hill
answer your questions give you dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon but
first does Jimmy have a poem for us
oh yeah Hank I've got a poem all right
well we're gonna split it yeah we're
gonna do a line each oh we're gonna read
it together
do you want to start Jimmy Mars ain't
the kind of place to raise your kids in
fact it's cold as hell and there's no
one there to raise them if you did and
all this science I don't understand it's
just my job five days a week a rocket
man a rocket man and I think it's gonna
be a long long time thanks for that that
lovely poem the the beautiful lyrics of
Bernie Taupin they're very prolific why
is this guy building rockets saying he
doesn't know anything about science for
surely that's kind of a fundamental
thing on your CV if your job is to
create space craft well I don't think
his job is to create space craft I think
his job is just to sit in the spacecraft
but it has always seemed kind of odd to
me that it's just his job five days a
week and now they're sending him to Mars
question mark because that's gonna take
a lot and you can't like come home on
the weekend so much oak that's what I
was gonna say oh yeah I had that one
ready Hank you paused for so long I
thought it simply needs to say something
I resorted to stealing a joke for the
sake of an awkward silence well there's
nothing quite as as hilarious as an
awkward silence so let's just have one
of those oh dear no I was like that's
the awkward silence that were edit out
that there it is I can't wait to see
that go so for everybody who doesn't
know charlie and Jimmy have both been
making YouTube videos for a long time
when did you guys start each Wow I
started back in 2007 I think late 2007
yes I was April 2007 I think that was me
all right I was Jan January 2007 so
we're all pretty old-school here and you
guys we are now all three of us working
together on a show but
you are the hosts of it I'm only very
behind the scenes behind the behind the
scenes called serial time which happens
every morning what's what's up a serial
time are you with at the serial time
studios now we are absolutely we're
recording with the very fancy
microphones we use on serial time and
just to say Hank you are always with us
in spirit you know you might not be with
us in the studio but you're constantly
in our minds and in our heart
record we have a picture of you just
above the lens of the camera yeah so
that we can always look at you and be
reminded where the money came from
that's not a real thing no but we might
do that now I've said it I'll go do it
now I well if I'm gonna come to England
sometime in the next year and I'm gonna
be on cereal time and I want to see
myself okay above the camera lens okay
we'll get like a huge six for oil
painting commissioned with with eyes
that follow you around the room yeah but
no yes zero times great so it's it's a
daily morning show sort of waking up
YouTube like a fern alarm clock waking
up the British YouTube because in
America it comes out at like midnight
and I'm like oh there it is morning in
England yeah every episode we do we get
at least five or six comments on the
time zone even now even though we've
been doing it like two months yeah it's
like is that morning shut up you guys
okay eventually it's fine yeah well
actually I buy I am tempted to leave
that comment and I've seen that comment
and also have and also know that this is
the thing that happens every single
video and yet when I see an episode of
cereal time come online and you tweet
good morning everyone
and I'm about to go to bed I am tempted
to leave that comment it's just a thing
that people want to do it's just how we
operate I did see you leave a comment on
one of the recent 0 times saying good
morning and I've only it's only just
struck me that that must have been a
very hard thing for you to have done so
good job well everyone else was saying
it yeah my mum always says every single
episode she leaves a comment saying good
morning
oh I love that all right well I'm loving
Zee real-time it's really fun and and
and hilarious and and weird and cute so
good job guys and now we're gonna ask us
some questions you guys want to answer
some questions oh yeah I wasn't told
about this
I haven't been told about it know what
what are we doing I thought we were just
doing a little ad for cereal time and
that was the whole thing got a answer
question that's no I'm ready it's fine
just inject some of that old comedy
Charlie resistor questions it's one of
his rules I can't make eye contact with
Charlie you can't ask Charlie a question
he's like the Korean you also have to
curtsy when you meet him for the first
time well luckily I did that but just
because I was super feeling awkward
there's nothing worse than an orchid
curtsey is there it's an awkward
movement at the best of times I
appreciated it all the same
did you actually curtsy when we met I
can't remember no I made that up oh I
mean it's possible
I do sometimes curtsy I think that it's
kind of Awesome I like the curtsy as an
introduction I I think that it is a it
is an interesting body movement that is
it is some can it is somewhat
complicated in its in its control of all
of your body parts and so I find it to
be more visually pleasing than a bow or
a handshake yeah do you think that's
where it evolves from do you think it's
just essentially a fancy bow I'd be
quite interested to hear the history of
the curse well we will who started that
who's the first person to do a curtsy
we're gonna we're gonna get people
telling us about that on Twitter I do
not doubt it
oh I cannot wait I cannot wait that's uh
it's it's at cool like and at high
underscore Jimmy and at Hank green so
let us know what's the history of the
curtsy should I do the first question
yeah yeah do they're worth question and
put your name first because that's how
it works
Halley asks dear Charlie and Jimmy and
Hank how do you avoid being pretentious
when your intelligence this is a really
hard one well I I first want to say that
pretentious might not have the exact
definition that that you think it
pretentious is like trying to look
important or trying to look intelligent
oh and often more intelligent or
important than you actually are
so so how do you avoid looking
pretentious while you're intelligent
maybe
is both the question you wanted to ask
and also a really good way of
illustrating how to look pretentious
what I just did by correcting your
grammar on that question yeah I mean so
pretentious is kind of the same it's
like having a delusion of grandeur isn't
it so I'd say if you are genuinely quite
knowledgeable about a topic and you're
speaking about it sincerely and
passionately no one will ever see that
as pretentious because it's it's coming
from an honest place you'll only come
across as pretentious if you're trying
to make out that you're clever than you
actually are
like you're just trying to sound smart
for the sake of sounding smart or and
actually you don't know what you're
talking about well I don't know that I
agree I felt like you can sometimes be
honestly smart like just really really
smart and then other people can see you
and if they don't know what you're
saying they can sometimes be like he's
just a bit pretentious isn't he because
it is both things it's both you know not
actually having the actual insight and
try to pretend that you have but it's
also just a perception that people have
a few well what I tend to do if I have a
fact that I want to get across I always
kind of try and preface it with some
kind of I don't know this for sure and
the universe is a confusing place and
who knows really what time is but here's
this thing I always try and slip like a
vibe of that into whenever I'm putting
across a fact like here's something that
I found out kind of separate it from me
yeah and I think there's just a case of
it it's a case of being aware if
somebody maybe isn't following you if
you're trying to explain something so if
somebody seems like they're a little bit
lost when you're chatting about
something that you happen to know a lot
about just just be aware of that and
explain things in a slightly simpler or
more accessible way and also also be
aware of the fact that people might not
care about the thing that you're excited
about and so they might be think that
you're pretentious because you
continually you know like are really
excited about things that you're really
excited about and they're like why does
he keep or why does this person
obviously just projected this onto
myself why does this person continually
try and make themselves look so smart
because they just might have different
different interests than you and that
that's a that's a
different kind of intelligence where
you're looking at a person and you're
saying you know like what is this person
like what are they into and how do I you
know interact with them in a way that
will make them excited to be my friend
and be talking to me and and also how do
I make this information sort of more
interesting to them like how do I put
myself in their shoes and say like
what's what's how is this topic gonna be
because everybody you know everybody is
going to get excited about things for
different reasons so maybe you know
think about that I have this problem
though and and sometimes people will say
things to me and I have this awful habit
of saying do you actually want to know
because which is a really pretentious
thing to say but it's like it's my
honest response like people are like god
why don't we have wireless chargers yet
why do we have to have all these cords
all around all the time and I'm like
well there's an answer to that question
but do you actually want to know it
because it's gonna take about five
minutes to explain and and well how do
you think how do you think you could
phrase that better than to be less
pretentious would you just notice a that
I think I think I should just not bring
it up I think I think what I know the
answer to a question that people are
asking rhetorically I like I think I
should just be like they are not they
are not actually interested in this but
then then sometimes I'm like well they
keep asking about it are they do they
want to know
should-should i launched into a
five-minute monologue on you know in
power induction and electromagnetism hey
that's someone or logo I want to hear so
gonna happen right now at cereal time
all right this isn't cereal time I
thought I am I think that's right though
I think actually you can just sort of if
you feel like you've been a little bit
pretentious or a little bit nerdy just
own up to that be like I'm aware that I
sound like a massive nerd now so stop me
if this gets boring but yeah then go on
no I
yeah excellent advice for me that is
what I will do next time I will be like
nice look there I'm a nerd and I and I
kind of want a lot I don't want to do
that but be aware that I'd know that I
you might want me to shop any second now
okay cool I like this this is from
Eileen and she says
dear Jimmy Charlie and Hank what are
your opinions on school uniform on
school uniforms and clothing
restrictions in non-uniform schools hmm
Wow
yeah I went to a school that had very
few clothing restrictions though I'm
sure that there were plenty and I'm sure
that they mostly restricted the clothes
of Gov of females because that's how it
goes
I can't distract the boys but yeah my I
did you guys have school uniforms yeah I
I when I was younger I remember watching
American teen movies and always being
baffled by this idea that in America you
can go to school wearing trainers and
jeans and really jealous yeah I had
school uniforms as well I also went to
an all-boys school so I didn't ever
experience any kind of like restrictions
that were put on girls it was just
restrictions on dudes
yeah did you have like a smart uniform
Jimmy it was quite smart
we we were a tie in fact I think the
last time I wore a tie in life was
because I had to a school that's the
only time it's ever happened but I quite
liked it because it meant that you never
had to think about what you wanted to
wear for school and everyone was kind of
on the same level like I think the
reason the uniform thing is a thing in
the UK is because it's supposedly it
gets rid of any class barriers because
like everyone's dressed the same like
you can't tell which kids are less
well-off than other kids which I quite
like it was always quite stressful when
we had non-uniform days and you had to
think of something cool to wear to
school because there's a huge deal
around it so it may be have one day of
the year where for charity you could
come into school like wearing your cool
sports top or a baseball cap yeah and I
always found that quite stressful I
don't know to where I need to make a
good impression oh god I feel like and I
think this is just this comes from like
if you go to school every day wearing a
uniform the one day of the year where
you don't have to do then kind of
becomes like you want to treat it like
it's a free day because you're kind of
used to wearing those clothes on the
weekends so I feel like less work
happens like less work tends to happen
on those days where you can just wear
whatever you want but I assume that if
you do wear whatever you want every
single day of the week that that doesn't
happen
that's my guess anyway so what are these
what are these clothing restrictions
then what
what what are you not allowed to wear
within that within the realm of
non-school well there's there you know
when you can wear anything there are
things you can't wear like you can't
have curse words or references to drugs
on your clothes you can't think there's
a a limit to the length or the shortness
of of like shorts and skirts often times
like it has to be a certain distance
from the knee and and and there's also
sometimes restrictions on the the the
depth of the cut of the neck was the way
that our school administrator would say
that and yeah wait so is the ratite
you're wandering around with the with a
ruler then and just making sure that the
come here no that's a centimeter how go
home Wow
it yeah I mean the to me I am in favor
of letting of allowing people to express
themselves and and identify em like and
create their identities and in whatever
ways they can that doesn't seem to be a
negative thing to allow people to do but
I do totally understand where you guys
are coming from where you know you sort
of like erase that very you know very
common and very difficult to ignore
class distinction though it's a way
because I feel like in any other
scenario
I'd like completely agree with you I
think it's just because living in that
world of having uniforms and never
really being a problem it's just kind of
what we're used to I guess and it was
always like a certain amount of freedom
to do some stuff like it would it would
always be quite surprising I think to
anybody looking at kids wearing school
uniforms like how much of themselves
they can get across by like the way that
they wear their tie and what they might
wear underneath their shirt and like
putting their blazer on their head or
whatever it might be
like there's always like ways to make it
so that you can show people the kind of
person you are so I never really felt
restricted but maybe I would have if I
was not used to it oh yeah I remember
that there's a whole there's a whole
like load of etiquette around how you
wear your school uniform at my school so
we had a shirt and a tie and then a
jumper over
the shirt and if you had the colors of
your shirt over your jumper that was
like a signifier that you were master
you were a massive nerd and that was the
thing that you didn't want to do you'd
get completely ripped apart for that so
it's funny how even within a uniform
like kids still find ways we have kind
of not only expressing yourself but
putting like cool signifies in there for
one of the barre phrase well eileen i
think that what we've got for you is
basically stories about our school hood
and very few actual opinions because
maybe this isn't a topic that super
matters a ton when it comes to uniforms
though I do feel like clothing
restrictions when it comes to that
seemed to out abnormally way upon the
the the females of the world which seems
a little bit odd to me
so maybe the school uniforms are a good
way to just avoid that particular
problem and say everybody wear this
let's not talk about anything else yeah
it's my turn we have a question from
Cortney who says dear Hank and Charlie
and Jimmy this upcoming presidential
election will be my first time able to
vote for a president it is both exciting
and daunting I think that I have a
general idea of who I might vote for but
I was wondering if there was any way to
keep abreast on the presidential
candidates oh wow you guys aren't
American but you are a politically
active British Pia we have public so you
could yeah we had yes very exciting
election a few months ago yeah it was
exciting quite depressing personally
yeah I mean the result was depressing
but the lead-up to it there was some
excitement there I think there's a lot
of optimism like oh maybe this is the
time it will change like maybe the good
guys will win and it did change it got
worse yeah it got a lot worse it got a
lot lot worse so we now don't have an
NHS and we've decided to get rid of the
school we've got our school anymore and
bring back killing foxes everyone oh
yeah and we can now kill foxes so it's
really great it's a really brilliant
place to live I don't understand the
u.s. election system particularly so oh
yeah it's very strange
it's very it's we got I'll get a whole
bunch of a bunch of weird
in our election system but but I think
that it the first time you vote the
first time you're getting into this it's
definitely daunting task to be like okay
here are all the issues there's like
eighty-five things I'm supposed to care
about and I'm gonna have an opinion all
of them so I better get one quick and
that's terrifying like why and that's I
think a lot of people don't a lot of
young people like their first elections
they might not vote just because like
they haven't had time to like deal with
that and internalize all of their
opinions about these things and because
they have to you know make ends meet and
and you know buy Gatorade and ramen so
the there are places though there's this
website called I think it's called eye
side with dot-com which sort of walks
you through all of the issues that it's
like what do you think about gun control
what do you think about bombing other
countries what do you think about
healthcare and sort of just based on
your who you are and what you think it
well then like not only it walks you a
little bit through the issues themselves
and like the different perspectives
people have on them and then and then it
tells you who you are most aligned with
politically in terms of the current
field of presidential candidates which I
did and found very accurate that's
really cool that sounds really really
great I think there's a similar app for
UK stuff as well which I used this year
and it worked pretty well but I guess
it's just like sort of learning about
any new thing isn't it you just need to
go away do a little bit of research try
not to be overwhelmed by it all because
it is quite like a clunky complicated
thing and it's like it almost feels like
quite a scary decision to make like to
choose the political part of your person
you want to align yourself with so just
try not to be overwhelmed by that and
just try your best to fill forming an
independent opinion and not be too
swayed by friends or family members or
stuff that people say on Twitter yeah on
that point of just feeling like you you
feel like you have to care about
absolutely everything all of a sudden
when I first started like when I was it
was my first time to vote what I did do
is I just like look to see what the
things were that were most important to
me and
that was kind of that's what he uses my
kind of benchmark for the figuring out
the kind of parties that I might be
interested in but I thought I mean that
in itself is quite hard isn't it because
you're sort of how you decide which
issues you care most about like do I
care most about NHS or like should
education be the thing I did always find
instinctively that was there was at
least one thing that was like oh yeah
but this yeah obviously really care
about that so if you can find whatever
that thing is if you can just sort of
trust your gut of oh yeah that thing I
actually yeah that's the thing I really
care about then maybe just fear around
the area and see what everyone's
policies are on education
yeah and just don't vote for one of the
bad ones yeah just just make sure you
don't ruin any country yeah simple as
that really
wow that was vetting advice I think you
guys are better at this than me and John
are and you should take over the show
and have your own maybe you should do
this every morning five days a week what
Charlie and Jimmy's political bit where
we just say no no talking just just
generally talking together ever like I
think every morning like you should just
you guys should just talk about stuff I
think you might have already had that
idea Hank Jimmy do you want to do
another question yeah I think it's your
turn there was no Charlie it is my turn
I mean I can read one hour oh I'm sorry
guy kids how do I join the queue keep
track you're both British I can't
how are you knew you'd really hope that
for non British viewers that you will be
able to tell me and Jimmy apart I think
we have pretty distinctive voices but
you do have very okay good all right we
got one from Lily she asks dear Charlie
and Jimmy and Hank hello what are you
supposed to do with other people and
just with other people and your stomach
that is how it's phrased and your
stomach makes a noise that sounds like a
fart and you want to tell everyone it
wasn't a fart but that would just make
it sound like it was a fart
his stomach makes a noise and it sounds
like a fart and you want to say that
wasn't a fart but as soon as you say
that was ok so everyone's like it was a
fact that wasn't it Lilly's stomach is
making fart noises essentially yes know
what to do about it I would say seek
medical advice
oh no no it's right you know i-i've
actually got experience of this I was
when filming for a TV show and I had a
microphone on under my shirt a little
lapel microphone and I wasn't feeling
great that day I think maybe I'd had
quite a late night and my stomach was
doing things I didn't want it to be
doing the next day and apparently this
was very audible on the microphone which
was under my shirt so embarrassingly in
front of a whole crew a whole room full
of people proper professional people
with cameras and and lights had to stop
filming until my stomach stopped making
these noises because it was ruining the
filming it was so embarrassing so I
totally feel your pain Lily and you kind
of just have to laugh it off like any
embarrassing thing yeah yeah the the
trick to dealing with embarrassment is
is self-confidence which is a trait that
is entirely impossible to acquire as far
as I can tell oh no come on
it's fake it till you make it is yeah
that's so that's what I've been trying
to do so you just try and pretend you
just act like a confident person and
then eventually you start being a more
confident person that's always been my
technical does I think I definitely
agree it's just you just say and is it
really you just don't have to try and
figure out how to not care about it as
much
that's and to get that across to people
turn it into a joke say guys it's just
my stomach yeah I I haven't farted but I
have pooped myself so I'm gonna have to
leave and then and then you know I think
that will sort out who your real friends
are as well no you got to say look I ate
a demon and I was helping my family it
was living in the house there's only one
way to kill it and it was to eat it
alive there's a very small diamond about
the size of a about the size of a coin
and just took it with water and now it's
in there it's doing its thing but you
know I've I'm gonna do digesting away
and it's it's it won't be a problem
tomorrow ah my bigger problem personally
is sometimes I really
have to fart in public and like like
yeah it's just not gonna not happen and
so even sometimes you have to be like
look you know what just I have to be
like that old guy who just doesn't care
anymore and it's just like and then
that's do you know like make an event of
it before it happens that's what I do
sometimes oh that's a good idea
III I build everyone up to it before it
comes oh it's like quiet in the room to
make sure everyone can hear it comes out
and then we try to move up by it so tiny
little drumroll and then that's the
crescendo yeah I do that a lot
[Laughter]
we've got some really good advice all
round here that's good yeah there you go
Lilly
all right so Catherine asks she says did
Jimmy Charlie and Hank I'm coming up on
the one-year anniversary of starting my
first full-time job I'm enjoying it and
I've learned to turn so far and I'm
planning to stay for a while longer but
also trying to think proactively about
my future do you have any advice for
developing an early career making adult
decisions about when and where to move
or how to go about looking for new
opportunities I'm also curious on how
one decides when to go back to school
and get a grad degree hmm Wow there's a
lot in there coverage yeah I mean that's
life in it that is that is life in a
question it's odd how do you make
decisions about big important things
it's really really hard and I feel like
I haven't I feel like I haven't lived a
lot of this stuff myself like I came
straight out of school went into making
YouTube videos never had to think about
getting a graduate degree never had to
yeah I just I I feel like I have to sit
this one out cuz I would be having more
trouble than you are Katherine right now
I think yeah I can I can totally see how
it's really easy to get trapped in
full-time employment because when
somebody starts paying you money every
month to do a thing that's quite it's
quite easy to get used to that even if
you don't necessarily enjoy the job the
money thing is quite nice especially if
you've not had that before so I guess
it's just about I don't know maybe
looking looking at where you want to be
the kind of your dream job your dream
life scenario seeing other people who
are in similar positions to that and
maybe look
how they got there and following a
similar route to them I don't know if
you have a job that doesn't it doesn't
look to you like this job is going to
lead to better jobs within the same
company or are you continuing to develop
your skills and and and you know
continuing to do different cool things
that excite or interest you then you
probably do want to be looking around at
least semi actively at like things that
your friends are doing things that if
you've been through college already
things that you're you know people who
graduated around the time same time as
you are doing and and yeah
and in being open to to that there's
nothing wrong with looking for other
jobs if you you know while you have a
job that is a totally normal thing and
you shouldn't be devoting like tons and
tons of time to that just because you
probably don't have that time to devote
and you should also have a life and
enjoy things but yeah I I think it's
totally normal and I expect you know
when I have employees that I feel like
they're being underutilized I expect
them to be looking for other jobs and
also as an employer I think that it's my
responsibility to make sure that they
aren't being underutilized at the
company so if I have an opportunity for
them to advance and to be doing
something more interesting than their
current job then I feel like that's my
responsibility and if I don't do that
then I should expect that they will
eventually leave and and that's one
reason why I you know when I when I look
at the people I've got working for me
and like I need to make sure that this
person in particular we find something
for them that's more interesting or less
awful than their current job and and
then they will not leave and go away and
not be working for me anymore so you
know I think that there's a lot to be
said for being really good at the job
you're at in right now because that will
affect you know you bike you you will
get better recommendations from your
current employer and it will also
potentially lead for two
getting you know promoted at your
current position whatever that position
is and yeah so I you know definitely
don't just think like this job is a
full-time job in like it's just the
money it's always good to be thinking
about how you can do your job really
well and I think that that has in my
life at least led to more personal
satisfaction when I'm not thinking about
it as just a paycheck I'm actually
thinking about it as like this is part
of my life and I'm spending a lot of
time doing this show I should be doing
it but you know I should be believing in
and doing the best job I can even if
it's not a job that I particularly love
where I think will lead me to my
ultimate dream I think that you know
working hard at whatever job you have
does kind of lead you toward your
ultimate dream because it exemplifies
your work ethic and and and how you
approach life so yeah I've had I've had
good luck with just working hard even if
I don't really like my job yeah and I
think when you reach that point where
you not only don't like a job but maybe
even if you do like a job but feel
you're not really getting anything out
of it then maybe that's a clue that it's
time to move on yeah like if you're not
getting anything out of this anymore if
you're not developing with it then
what's the point yeah and you can you
can absolutely I encourage you to talk
to your your supervisory manager your
boss about that because when when I have
I always I like that when people come to
me and they say like look I feel like I
could be doing more interesting things
and here are some of the more
interesting things I think I could be
doing and you know I often agree with
them and I'm like hey yeah good ideas
because I can't have all the ideas it's
quite a hard one to answer though
without knowing what Katherine's job is
like she could have an amazing job she
could be a millionaire she could be like
some like high-flying exec who gets to
jet around the world
we just don't know yeah I mean I'm I'm
trying I'm trying to answer this
question in a way that works for both
someone who works at a fast-food
restaurant
and someone who works in I right it's my
turn again this question is from Daniel
who says do your Hank and Charlie and
Jimmy do you think science scientific
thinking can
right from wrong are there objective
ways to measure morality another big one
Wow can you go back to the font ones
this is too odd what do you think ANCA
this is a really tricky one no I don't
think that there are objective ways to
measure morality I so like Kant had his
idea of the categorical imperative which
was like this is the way to create a
universal morality and the way to create
the universal morality was you know you
should behave in a way that you that you
think if everyone behaved in the same
way as me then then the world would work
really well but that doesn't work
because not everyone will behave the
same way as you and people and different
cultures believe and act in different
ways and that has to be okay because
otherwise if we are you know like the
the one thing that that breeds is
intolerance and then saying like look
the way that you guys live your lives is
wrong and is destroying the idea of what
it is to be human and thus we must kill
you and that's where all the big
problems come from I think that I think
that this was a sort of idea of moral
absolutism is what creates a lot of
conflict thinking about it I feel like
there maybe is a way to objectively
measure morality without having that
kind of like absolute morality I guess
because I feel like in that case isn't
morality it's ultimately what people
perceive morality to be so maybe if
there was a way where you could kind of
speak to every single individual on the
planet and ask them every question every
big important question in every small
question related to morality and ask
them what their opinion was then you
could come up with a percentage maybe
that said you know trying to think of
something like petting a dog is 99%
moral according to the human race that's
the best I could come up with dessert
sounds feasible or is that just I'm
trying to figure out a way to answer
this question where I can say yes
somehow and that was my best
Ziya so the there's two different things
there's there's allowing every person to
define their own morality which i think
you have to do to a small extent but
then there's the larger version of
allowing a culture to define its
morality and and I think that that that
is the thing like you kind you can say
like you know there is a structure that
we define as humans it is the thing that
we call culture and it is different for
different people and we there is
definitely I think there are ways to
evolve that and to make that you know
more tolerant is the thing that I tend
to want cultures to be but in terms of
the nitty-gritty specific details like
petting a dog versus versus a cat like
which one of these things is more moral
there's definitely gonna be some gray
area there there's even weird gray area
with with with something as seemingly
unobjective or seemingly as objective as
like murder where you have some cultures
that are like yeah like an America where
it's okay to kill people as long as the
government has gone through a lengthy
and expensive process to say that yes we
should kill this person because they did
something very bad and in some countries
that and in fact in my own personal
morality I think that that is that is
wrong and then you have war which is
just like how do we rationalize this but
we seem to so I mean that's I mean
morality in general is such a difficult
thing to rationalize and I think it'd be
impossible to ever reach a full
consensus with it because you've gotten
you know literally hundreds of thousands
of years of history that has kind of
shaped our morality and the human
condition I mean that's what it comes
down to isn't it it's a very it's a
human thing and I think it's it's what
you know if we if we could reach a full
consensus we'd become a bit more robotic
as a society yeah and I like the idea
that we change and we evolve and
hopefully we had in in good directions
and I think there's also a thing here
that is the desire to scientifically be
able to say everything and there are
just some things that we cannot
scientifically talk about like there are
some questions that science isn't
supposed to answer the scientist science
isn't designed to answer things like
what is the difference between right and
wrong which you know I think that's
that's a human question that that every
every human has to decide and then
collectively a culture decides and then
collectively cultures joined together
and decide for the world and you know I
think that greater stability will be had
if if we have some standardization there
and that standardization involves
tolerance of other cultures and other
people that's yeah and but like it's
it's impossible to say mm-hmm I've got
an even trickier question here Angela
asks dear Charlie and Hank and Jimmy
what were your best and worst subjects
when you're at high school whoa the big
questions here wowser I really liked are
you and so on brilliant hours into what
I've kind of blocked the whole of school
yeah I I really enjoy it so I've decided
to forget about it I I mean I put this
question in the notes and I can't really
remember
I like why aren't my report cards
searchable on Google so I could look
this up oh god it mattered I don't want
my reports out there I remember that I
was terrible at sport that was
definitely my worst subject at school I
was the kid who would always have some
made-up ailment that would stop me
playing tennis
whatever yeah I always had a note so yes
I mean sport was just horrible I mean my
memories of sport at school were just
cold wet gray days on a frozen rugby
field having a ball thrown at me I did
that terrible thing where as soon as I
realized I wasn't amazing at it I pretty
much gave up like my first when I first
went to secondary school I was like yeah
I'm going to do sport and it's gonna be
great and I tried to play rugby and I
tried out for the team and I got in the
second team so I didn't get in the first
team and then I was like and then I just
never was interested in sports again
there's a lot of sense like sin since
I've got to know you better
through working on cereal time quite
closely like we hang out like at least
two or three times a week you're
actually secretly quite competitive oh
I'm very well it's not a secret anymore
but yeah and out there I am competitive
I just think don't make like to make a
pointed it like I don't like to make a
point of it when were actually competing
yeah and it's not in a horrible way like
it's not in a really gross like kind of
soccer mom tight way yeah it's like it's
just it's something that's there I just
like winning and I know I think it what
it is is I just find myself getting
really embarrassed when I lose that's
that's really what it is okay well you
kind of the kid who if he was losing the
race would just throw themselves down I
might pretend to have a knee injury I'm
you I was usually like it still happens
right now like if I try and play a board
game with people and I'm on like a team
and I can't write quite figure out the
answer to give the like playing
pictionary and it's not quite going well
I would just be like mortified it's like
so horribly embarrassed I will just like
not have a good time at all
so that's that's me inside Charlie
McDonnell like I did like PE that sounds
about right really yeah sorry I can't
remember I I definitely did well I don't
think that I well no I was good at
memorizing stuff which was most of
American education I just I feel like I
did I did well in most things I didn't
really ever get a C until until college
but I do remember that I almost failed a
class in landscape design so like the
the placing of plants around around a
yard well it's not a real classification
of a home and I almost failed that class
because I skipped it too many times but
I had a freakout and I screamed and I
kicked you know I ran I stormed out of
the classroom and I I beat up a locker
and then the teacher was like maybe
we'll take a couple of these absentees
off of your
of your record Wow let you have the B so
yeah I would love that class to see but
i but i freaked out and it saved me i
would love to see you to play a board
game together that would be incredible i
think that there would certainly be
tears possibly violence we're not done
thanked and I felt like it was my mother
played a board game that we played card
games before I felt like I played a card
game with you at VidCon last year but no
really yeah well obviously it wasn't a
big deal for you oh we should we should
though we have we got the guys from
drunk drunk beer and board games drunk
my drunk a beer and board games are
going to be at at VidCon this year so
maybe we can make maybe we could play
with them do you do you drink charlie I
do yeah this is a this is going back to
you know changing you and what you think
is moral at a certain extent obviously
drinking isn't sort of like a huge issue
but over the course of the last couple
years I have started drinking I was
completely teetotal for a long time like
I was teetotal I knew I was detailed
before I even was old enough to actually
drink like when I was 16 I was like I am
never gonna drink and yeah that has that
has changed if you look very closely in
Charlie's last six vlogs he's completely
drunk in every single one of them he can
barely stand up we get this is art this
is our last question of the questions
before we get to the news this one's
from grace who says dear Hank and
Charlie and Jimmy my friend's little
sister has a toy remote-control car that
started moving and lighting up on its
own they've had it for five years and
the batteries haven't been changed since
they got it they got used to it and
never had a rope they got they got it
used and it never had a remote control
recently the headlights lit up and
started moving a little forward and back
that's not what it says they got they
got it used they got it used and it
never had a remote control recently the
headlights lit up and it started moving
a little forward and backward any idea
what might be happening charlie is it a
ghost
um yeah exorcise it yeah facts exercise
not exercise exercise exercise no
exercise it just give
good workout we're out and then it will
be a wonderful once it's nice and tired
it was not moving that's why men that
actually would work if we want to make
it stop moving you just you just keep it
moving for a long enough or you know
take the batteries out ya know that
would be a I yeah it's definitely a
coast I think I think we've established
on this podcast that when I when I was
uh when I was I actually did a little
research on this question because I
wanted to see if like radio
transmissions from nearby things whether
that was you know radio controlled
microphones or somebody's
radio-controlled airplane that might
have a really strong transmitter or a
you know a drone or something might be
you know making this thing move like
picking this thing might be picking up
those signals so I that is possible that
is a thing that can happen it is also
possible that it is has a loose wire but
I did find in the first like like this
was not an uncommon ly searched question
and in the first like three responses
there was a ghost bulletin board for
that was like yes it is probably a ghost
and I was like like wow that they sure
did have that answer you know really
ready to go I like the idea of the of
the undead just deciding to possess a
remote-control car that's how they're
connected planet Earth I'm going to take
over that remote control car it's just a
really bashful ghosts yes I don't really
want to possess people yeah I'll just
have a go in this little car just just
move it back and forth a little less
that's me done hey maybe the spirit
world don't get a choice maybe it was
just like ah right so I'm a ghost but
I'm a remote-controlled car great
brilliant this is I would watch this
movie tell tell me more
I'm almost definitely sure I was
watching Freddie Wong's channel recently
and I saw that they I think he did like
a sketch of some sort where it's like a
cop gets possesses a remote-control car
and that's like in its the everybody
loves the car and it's it's great at
doing its job so I think I might be
taking I mean my sister used to have a
Furby and that in itself what if it's
ghost possessed a Furby I mean that was
supposed to be terrifying
oh my god I mean now it's like Chucky
except with the Furby there's this sort
of wobbling around slowly being menacing
it'll be really hard to have for a Furby
actually hurt you I feel like is they
they can't grasp things or move their
arms but I know they just have to crush
you psychologically yes that's what I'd
be so creepy about it no they lay a
finger on you that would be really
that'd be a really good a good a good
horror movie just just psychologically
crushing like they'd trap you in a room
and then they they just every time you
fall asleep they they just scream at you
and terror terrorize you and that's
that's the whole movie it's just not
letting you ever forget that you have
this this possessed toy that'll be
pretty low budget well I think we could
do that if we win it and now it is time
for the news from Mars the fourth planet
in our solar system and AFC Wimbledon a
fourth tier English soccer team guys do
you have any AFC Wimbledon news for us
with glee and amazement I bring you
probably very important news the the the
Dons have signed scuffle United striker
Lyle Taylor for wait for it an
undisclosed fee whoo Taylor I I feel so
bad for John I feel so bad I felt like
III initially wanted to do this with
like genuine enthusiasm because I feel
like the most the best bit of like you
know this whole news new section is the
fact that John is so actually excited
about this this football team that is so
small but it's too difficult yeah while
Taylor
they hide him undisclosed fee he sky he
he scored four times in 25 appearances
last season whoa wow wow 4 out of 25 is
that good in football I don't know
anything about football it's amazing
incredible I go I don't I read that
statistic I didn't believe it so he
really is worth is undisclosed fee
I mean I'm trembling with excitement
right here III don't think I've ever
been this excited before I've got some
oh no this is a continuation of that
news story
not over guys oh no Neal Ardley the
manager of the Don's said he was
interested in Taylor because he has very
good movement and technique his
finishing is very good and he is also
quick of course I have no idea whether
that's a big deal or not it sounds
impressive I mean that's literally the
first thing that came up when we search
for AFC Wimbledon so I think that means
it's good I mean it's a player they got
a new plan that's a that's a big
football deal
that's definitely news that's definitely
news it's an actual deal it has been
made it is a deal admit yes and now they
have a new striker which is a great name
for a position on a football field he
strikes things sounds sounds very
impressive I think mostly balls you know
he's got a good movement and technique
that's what that's the manager saying
that an expert he's got good movement
and technique and his finishing is very
good what's not to like there also I've
done some more he is also quite done
some more research wimbledon have not
disclosed the length of his contract
no that's true yeah
interesting they don't we don't know how
long he'll be it's just so much mystery
wrapped up in this all right I got some
Mars news and Mars news some very
surprising rocks were found in Gale
Crater by the Curiosity rover this week
the rocks which are striated and dense
with silica are completely unexpected
and very similar to granite rocks that
one might find here on earth most Mars
rocks we find are clearly igneous rocks
but this granitic rock containing quartz
and feldspar means that Mars probably
billions of years ago had continental
plates that drifted just like Earth's
those plates have long since frozen in
place but these rocks indicate that Mars
was once even more earth-like than we
previously imagined that's really
interesting I I found out recently the
was the only planet with tectonic plates
and now that has been squashed by yet
more science yeah but I've told you that
I got to see the Curiosity rover before
it was on Mars right no I haven't told
you that I feel like I must have at some
point even though you just genuinely
don't remember any interactions we've
ever had seems to be a possibility not a
good remember I will say that okay
that's fine yeah no I got I
lovely men from over from NASA showed me
around the the Jet Propulsion labs
before curiosity was sent off to Mars so
I got to I got to see it didn't get to
touch it saw it through a window so lots
of people working on it but it was there
in front of me and it was very exciting
that's a big thing and no they do not
they do not like you to touch things
like that I got and got to see some
pieces of the James Webb Space Telescope
and they made me put on all kinds of
special clothes my special clothes I
mean pretty hat told ya I'm imagining
sort of like a Victorian ball gown right
now no it's just it was just a British
schoolboys uniform okay so nothing weird
this blazer and a tie and surely I put
my I put my collar on top of the blazer
so that everyone knew I was a total nerd
I will say this about my experience and
I said yeah so jet propulsion labs the
guy I met at best I forget his name and
I feel bad about that but he was so
smart and I spent like a good like 80%
of that trip just sort of nodding while
he said stuff that just went completely
over my head it was so hard to keep up
with him but I still found him awesome
being there that's how I felt with the
surprising rocks that you've just read
out Hank I had no idea about any of that
understand I
I'm not really a geology guy either so I
didn't know most of what I just said I
just said the stuff that it said in the
article that I was paraphrasing I just
love the idea that there are surprising
rocks out there that that's a thing I've
never been surprised by a rock there in
Montana we have these things called a
radix
which are which are exactly surprising
rocks is exactly what they are they are
rocks that shouldn't be here
so that they are erratic rocks and they
they are mostly deposited by the
recession of glaciers during ice ages so
there will be this big rock that just
doesn't belong and it's like how did
this giant rock that has nothing to do
with the local geology get here and it's
like oh yeah it was carried along by a
glacier and the blasier melted and then
it was there oh that's really cool
that's cool yeah rising rocks yeah
surprising rock the new feature and now
muse from surprising rocks alright that
is it for this episode of dear Hank and
John without John and guest hosted by
the hosts of serial time Charlie
McDonnell and Jimmy Hill thank you guys
for joining us thank you
does this mean that there are more dear
Hank and John podcast without John
element I think that we I think that we
are now equal the number of John
episodes that there are and and that
next week we will we will it will no
longer be mostly dear Hank and John it
will be mostly dear Hank and other
people but then John will come back and
we will we will overtake that that total
once again though I wouldn't be
surprised if it hits roughly 50/50 and
kind of like wibbels around that mix for
the next couple of years as John
continues to do too many things I think
you just need to audition for a new
brother Hank you need to do like an X
Factor star audition thing who will be
the new John and he might be doing that
right now we don't know yeah may all of
these people is token to know this could
be the audition all right everybody our
theme music is by gonna roll the podcast
as edited by Nicholas Jenkins if you
have any questions for us you can please
send them to Hank and John at gmail.com
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome we did our best
like a barbershop quartet
[Music]